اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه ونحن في
اليوم الرابع من المواجهات العنيفه بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع حيث
اعلنت لجنه اطباء السودان ارتفاع عدد
القتلى بين المدنيين جراء الاشتباكات الى
144 وارتفاع عدد المصابين من المدنيين
والعسكريين الى
1409 لجنه اطباء السودان اكدت خروج العديد
من المستشفيات والمرافق الصحيه عن الخدمه
وطالبت بفلح ممرات امنه لمعالجه المصابين
وتوصيل الادويه هذا وافاد ايضا مراسل
العربيه مشاهدينا بتجدد الاشتباكات في
محيط سلاح المهندسين بمدينه ام درمان وذلك
وصدر ارتفاع دوري المدافع في المنطقه في
وقت سابق مشاهدينا من ليل الاثنين الى
الثلاثاء الجيش السوداني كان اعلن عزمه
توسيع نطاق عملياته العسكريه وطلب من
المواطنين الحيطه والحذر واوضح البيان ان
الجيش بات يسيطر على معسكر لقوات الدعم
السريع في ام درمان
هذا فيما تستمر المواجهات في محيط القصف
الجمهوري بالخرطوم
قوات الدعم السريع ايضا مشاهدينا قالت من
جههها انها تسيطر بشكل كامل على مطار
الخرطوم وانه مستمرون في المعركه كما
حققوا انتصارات متواليه الممثل الخاص
الامين العام في السودان
تحدث بدوره عن مقتل
185 مدنيا وعسكريا سودانيا وجرح اكثر من
1800 مدني وعسكري
ونتابع معكم مشاهدينا هذه الصور المباشره
من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم ونسم فيها
الى اصوات هذه الاشتباكات بين قوات الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع نستمع الى
ازيزا الرصاص ودوي المدافع واصوات
الانفجار والتي تجري في محيط القياده
العامه ومحيط القصر الجمهوري ايضا في
خرطوم وبيت الضيافه
ومحيط المطار مطار الخرطوم الذي قالت قوات
الدعم السريع قبل قليلها سيطرت عليه بشكل
كامل في انتظار ما يؤكد او ينفي ذلك من
قبل القوات المسلحه السودانيه
في متابعه هذه الصور المباشره من العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم ودعونا نستمع اليها
بصوتها الطبيعي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات